oh
right then
tells me i'm live i'll find out in a
minute
hopefully people can hear me
we'll find out shortly hello to all on
the chat hopefully you are hearing me
had a little bit of an issue because i
i've been using um
the obs uh streaming app to stream
through twitch
and
um
i
normally only use that for youtube so
i'd switch my settings back
for youtube but i screwed that up
slightly i think i got it sorted
oh looks like i did excellent hello all
hello there caroline gozer ms wicked
wolf
vacuum of comments
john name nameless
purposeless the seventh mr sorry
um
lewis ward mr critical cara i saw a
cappuccino crap yep cappuccino crafts is
in fairies
nevermore i know meg was in i saw that
she was in earlier i hope you're feeling
at least a little bit better i know
things were a little bit off earlier
how's life
life is um
life is a journey life is a highway and
i want to write it all night long um
it's fine i just finished editing uh
saturday's video
so for um
for patreon supporters that'll go up uh
for early access actually probably
tonight
yes i have grapes
um
did i hear about estelle harris i did
um
you know the
heart goes out to
her friends and family oh good meg you
are still here that's that's i mean
that's a starting point
still be here it's a baseline
um estella harris i wasn't like a huge
fan of most of the stuff she's best
known for but you know
it's always sad and i'm sure that people
who knew her personally will miss her
greatly
but that's that's kind of uh
it's kind of where i'm at with that
have ever have i ever watched you on
netflix i haven't liz watches that that
is one of liz's
trash shows to put on while she has a
bunch of work to do because she doesn't
think it's worth her devoting her full
attention to it it's one of those shows
for her it's the same with riverdale um
so i have not watched it i've heard
plenty liz quite enjoys telling me about
shows especially her garbage shows i
think she enjoys telling me about her
garbage shows more than anything else
i wake up in the last tv show i watched
this is now your life where are you if
it's the last tv show i watched then
that would be
uh our our flag means death
which
i've only finished the first episode of
and
i'm hoping to like it better
we'll go with that for right now
all i wanted in this world is some
batman stories with no joker that be
nice
wouldn't it like there's plenty of other
villains
is she enjoying the current season of
riverdale i don't think she's what she
doesn't watch it as she airs she watchs
it once it becomes streamable um so she
won't get to the current season for a
little bit
but she'll get there eventually
have i ever watched misfits no i have
not
watching money heist my girlfriend
introduced me to it don't know that one
hoping our flag means death does well
uh reese derby deserves to be a much
bigger star it's doing well i know it is
uh it's doing quite well actually
um
oh watching sense8 john bainbridge i i
still n liz and i need to get back to
that we've been really bad about
getting back to that
uh goodness
june brown who played lady eleanor in
the time warrior passed away sunday age
95. she was a legend over here in the uk
for her role in eastenders oh
well
95 she had a good run
have i seen people in the age of the
wonderbeast my kid and i just started
watching that
and now that we've finished uh steven
universe
and i've i've got all of my um all my
reviews out for that that's what we've
uh started watching we're only like two
episodes in
so far uh she's having to get used to
longer length episodes again she got
very used to the 11 minutes of uh
of stephen but
um
solid start so far we'll see if if it uh
holds her attention well enough to stick
with it i think it's got a good shot
have i seen poorly animated doctor who
i'm assuming that's a youtube channel
if so uh no i have it oh who brought up
the ventriloquist i love the
ventriloquist he's one of my favorite
batman villains
have i seen the animated batman movies
with adam west i did yes um i liked the
first one a little bit better than the
second one although the gimmick of
bringing william shatner to be two-faced
in the second one was very welcome um
but yes i actually own the first one on
blu-ray
are you quite emotive generally
sometimes i find you slightly scary my
own family issues
um
it varies
let me put it this way i'm not gonna say
i'm super emotive as default
but i can get worked up
um so that's the thing that can happen
and like
this is something that like i've had to
i've had to become more
aware of again uh because since for the
last year and a half now
more than that even i'm you know
well i mean two years just in terms of
working from home and working for myself
for the last year
you know year eight months or whatever
um
i've gotten used to
basically only directly interacting with
people who know me well enough to know
that when i get worked up and get on a
roll about something i'm not actually
angry at them i'm just i've just got a
lot to get out
and when i have interactions with people
who have not been around me as much or
don't know that about me i have to be
careful because like i come across as
frankly too intense i've had that happen
it's something i'm trying to become
aware of again because i haven't really
had to be aware of it for a while i mean
like liz knows this about me my family
knows this about me most of the people
at the burlesque communities who know me
well know this about me but
you know
trying to uh trying to rein that back in
slightly oh i forgot to mention uh while
i do try and keep up with the chat uh
super chats
are one of two ways to guarantee that i
will see and address your question or
comment the other way being if you are a
patreon supporter there is a channel in
the discord uh for questions and we'll
i'll be checking that at quarter to
eight
according to my time so in about um 40
minutes a little bit less than that
um and
super chat here guarantees that i will
see and address your commenter question
you also get a heart from me for that so
thank you very much
and let's see
have i seen last night in soho i have
not yet
at last i checked i was waiting for it
to be free streaming somewhere i haven't
checked that in a little bit though so i
don't know if it is yet
i can relate i can get too intense as
well
uh do you play cards against
uh humanity
i haven't played that game in years
i'm not because like i'm playing this
again i'm just not i'd like i haven't
been in an environment to even like play
games with i have a i have a game i
can't remember what it's called now i
have a game i got for either
christmas or
a birthday a couple years ago
that's like in the vein of cards against
humanity that still never
played ah
it's april and it's still 50 degrees see
you say that it's difficult to play oh
it's still 50 degrees and it's april i'm
in vermont 50 degrees is what it's
supposed to be we had snow two days ago
so
um
have i seen oh megan vincent thank you
very much for the super chat much
appreciated have you seen any
transformer shows thoughts
basically no i've seen like tiny bits in
pieces here and there
um
but i've never like
watched
i think even a complete episode of any
of them
i've only ever seen like all the way
start to finish the animated movie and
the first live-action movie
the animated movie was interesting uh
fascinating actually in a lot of ways
and the live-action movie was not very
good and by the time i'd seen that the
second one had already come out
um
and people were like oh well the first
one was way better and i didn't really
like the first one so
then like
as it continued to be the case of
everyone being like oh first one's the
best one i'm like i don't even like the
first one i've never gone back to the
live action ones have i seen killing eve
i
have not yeah i haven't seen that one
uh
do i like bacon usually not by itself i
mean i'll grab a piece but like i like
it as a supplement on something
oh notice noticing the mug adrenaline
uh it's
um it is stealth promotion
which doctor
did it feel the most wrong when they
were without a companion
um
i go back and forth between fourth and
eleventh
felt
felt off i would say too except i don't
think he ever actually was companionless
he would have been lost without a
companion
omega supreme
thank you so much for the super chat
thoughts on babylon 5 so far season 1
can be a bit slow i don't think it's
slower than um
than anybody else
anybody else any other show um sort of
in the same vein that's trying to build
a bigger continuing story
um
i mean
here's what i'll say
i've heard from multiple people from
multiple angles whether it's slow or
boring or or you know the effects are
real if you're what have you that season
one's a little rocky
um and with that in mind i can say i can
see the seeds of stuff that i'm really
gonna latch on to like i'm really
digging when it gets into political and
philosophical elements
um some of the more surface level stuff
it's it's a little rocky but
um there's definitely stuff that i'm
latching on to that i am enjoying
and if you're not listening to the
podcast yet i encourage you to do so i
am complaining a bit like at this point
but i've i've been emphasizing at the
end of each podcast i'm like i am
enjoying this it's just i'm
me so
yeah complaints happen
your snow came here yesterday thankfully
the temps were hovering near zero so we
had more rain ah
uh have you heard that jodi whitaker's
final episode is apparently going to be
90 minutes long
um i've heard confirmation it was
feature-length i mean that's not
shocking
um
given you know some of the longer stuff
that has the show has done just in
general
um
last few years i wouldn't be surprised
by that
i hadn't heard it
like normally i'd go citation edited but
i'm like i believe that and if it's not
the case then whatever
um have i seen brand new animals also on
netflix i've not even
heard of that one so
uh that's a new
interesting fact about tmnt versus
batman both batman and the joker are
voiced by the same person troy baker who
is an absolute powerhouse in the va
world i'm familiar with troy baker i
actually have some issues with troy
baker um not like
deeply problematic person but he holds
some views on the
on the state of the business
that i find unhelpful but he's not a bad
guy and
i i'm hoping i'm hoping when i get
around to watching the darn thing it's
actually sitting right over there um
that he's not that he's doing his own
joker and he's not just doing the hamel
joker which is what i've heard him do
when i've heard him do joker before
and like
that's fine
and all but you know i don't need
someone who isn't mark hamill to do the
mark hamill joker
i can do the mark hamill joker
come on batsy
you used to be fun
like i can do that myself
what's my favorite animated show that
and that is actually really hard
to answer because a lot of my favorite
shows are animated
i suppose it's probably
it's probably the max
the uh
the mtv animated series
um
but there's a lot of candidates
loving the jump gate podcast agreeing
with your nitpicking 100 that helps to
hear
what is the most chilling death in
doctor who that you have seen or heard
uh
childrenic and the holy terror
uh take some beating yeah i'm hmm
i have to think about that
none of them have really like deeply
stuck with me
so i i don't have an answer off the top
of my head
i recently rewatched orphan55 call me
crazy i think it's so bad it's good
so bad it's good is really
really rare for me um by and large
things that other people are like it's
so bad it's good for me like i just i
get bored
i'm like and that's the main thing
most bad movies or bad shows
bore me
um it has to be truly
nonsensical and the thing is most things
that people like oh it's so bad it's
good are
like they're not bad for interesting
reasons
as far as i'm concerned like something
that's bad because it's badly made or
had a low budget
or whatever like that's that's not
interesting to me i'm not saying this is
the case with 55. but like a lot of so
bad it's good stuff falls under that and
like that's not interesting to me i'm
kind of i kind of side with yahtzee
crochet on this that the most
fascinating bad things
are things made competently
but the creative decisions make no
freaking sense
where it's not just a failing of budget
or skill like they had the skill to
execute the vision it's just the vision
was what
what
uh did i see nameless's inquiry i think
i missed it um i can
try and
back it up and find it uh oh uh did you
get my email with my fan art yes i did i
did uh because i replied to you
initially
and then you sent me the finished
version i meant to reply to that too
and i didn't because my memory is crap
and i was
bogged down on other stuff so yes i did
i did and i love it it's great it's
great
i appreciate that much
oh
cara thank you very much i had a child
ask me today if he could count me as one
of his rectangles because of your tummy
realized hours later i'm wearing a
sleeveless sweater i call it a vest but
not sure if that's uh what it is in the
u.s yeah it would be a sweater vest in
the u.s
[Laughter]
yeah no a question like that would have
thrown me off too so
i think that's a that's a fair reaction
uh
oh
tara staller thank you so much for the
super chat i know this is more jesse
gender's thing but do you or have you
watched any star trek uh and if so do
you have a favorite series
um
also heart
um
yeah i like star trek i i generally
don't um
call myself a
star trek fan
because like there is no star trek
series that i've seen all of the only
star trek thing i've seen all of is i've
seen all the movies
uh you know the original cast next
generation and the reboot
but as far as the shows go i've seen
sporadic and a handful
of the original
series
i um
the most i've seen is next generation
which is my favorite
i've seen very little
ds9 i've seen a couple of episodes of
voyager i've seen no discovery i've seen
one episode of enterprise i've seen one
episode of lower decks
um there's uh there's honestly it's too
dang much
um
there's just there just is so much star
trek especially at this point like even
running concurrently and it's like ah
um
and i i don't have
well i do enjoy star trek i'm not
invested enough in it to sink the kind
of time into it as say like i do with
marvel because i have i've been with
marvel for long enough and i'm i don't
have a backlog of stuff i just get to
keep up with whatever's new whereas the
idea of like getting current with star
trek involves
a monstrous backlog in addition to all
the new stuff that's coming out
i do want to try and get to picard
season two because i did see season one
of that
don't remember all that much about it um
but
[Laughter]
i should should try and get that in
uh also when asked if andy sandberg
would do
another dc film specifically superman he
said no because to quote him there are
so many interpretations of him
uh you'll take someone off no matter
what which is accurate it's a strange
reason to not do it but accurate
um
excuse me
did i see jxe's analysis on doctor who
oh yeah
i saw that
they were very thorough and very fair
they they
backed up everything they said that's
why the thing's five hours long it was
very strange to me where there was like
um
[Music]
a backlash to that
from within the doctor who community
um because like it's not a five hour it
wasn't five hours of them screaming
it was five hours long because
they backed up every single criticism
they had with evidence as to why they
felt this way and why they felt this was
a problem
that's why it's as long as it is
yes agreed meg uh miss wicked wolf i've
been deliberately ignoring your
backstreet boys question meg's got you
pegged right there
do you agree that one thing chidnal did
right is making recurring villains
threatening again like cybermen weak
being angels and the son tyrons
ah
no
[Laughter]
no
i would say that
to my taste he almost did that
um
like the lone cyberman assad
is such a brilliant concept that then
gets junked and nothing gets done with
i don't like village of the angels
i didn't like it at the time it aired
and when seeing the entirety of flux
that did not move my opinion even
slightly and i know i'm alone in that
probably less so now that people
realized how empty the whole thing was
um but definitely at the time yeah no
people
people heavily disagree with me about
that so no i disagree there so the
santarans were very well done i don't
think threatening's the word though what
i will say is he did make them not a
joke
i hesitate to say that he made them
threatening i feel like that's a step
further than he got but he did bring
them back without making them a joke
which is what they'd become
under a moffatt so
yeah
i would say he handled the suntaren's
best and he had a really fascinating
idea with the cybermen that went
flipping nowhere
uh that video was recommended for me but
five hours is a lot i'm here for an hour
or two but three hours is about my limit
i'd like to be fair it's broken up into
chapters there are definitely points
where you can stop and take a break
question what do you consider a badass
female character for me
bayonetta that is all i
i mean
you're asking me at a time when i've
recently finished farscape so aaron sun
springs to mine
for sure
on the chilling desk then who sky man
um
i don't i don't think the deaths in sky
man were inherently chilling
i just think the direction of the story
was what was chilling the fact that if
the deaths themselves weren't like you
removed the deaths from the context what
happened to the people was
not great but
i didn't find it exceptionally
disturbing what's disturbing about that
is just the general direction of the
whole dang story
um that story is brilliant by the way
that's a that's a big finished story for
people who don't know
have i seen or am i going to see morbius
um
i have not seen it
and it's given the given the reaction
not at the top of my list
i mean i may end up liking it more than
most because like
critics dumped on venom i liked both of
those so who knows but like it's not
high on my priority list right now
um
do you oh sorry uh super chat omega
supreme do you feel the sequel trilogy
is
the clone saga of star wars it starts
with promise
ends in a mess
uh
revive norman equals revive palpatine
jackal equals snoke
um
that's
i'm not sure how many parallels there
are but that's not i
it's not a completely off-base
comparison i mean the main reason it
doesn't quite work as a comparison is
the reason the spider-man clone saga
ended up the way that it did and the
reason that the star wars ended up uh
the star wars trilogy ended up the way
they did are
a bit different the only way in which
they crossover has to do with the very
last film because that one was rushed
but the main problem with the clone saga
for spider-man was that they kept not
lending it letting it end the writers
kept going okay here's how we're going
to end it and then editorial went no
keep it going so
the reasons why they became messes um
aren't really comparable although some
of the story elements yeah it's not a
million miles off
john vinyls thank you very much thoughts
on horizon zero dawn and horizon
forbidden west i have none i have played
neither i don't plan to fully realized
uh freak free roaming camera
3d games uh give me motion sickness so
no plans to play
the next series of the war master is
going to have master face off against
the 10th doctor ooh interesting
what version of a christmas carol do you
recommend a muppet christmas carol it's
always a good go-to
um
i like that one a lot i like i actually
like the uh the patrick stewart one that
one's pretty good and um
the george c scott won that's good as
well
uh and if you have nostalgia for the 80s
scrooged still holds up better than
you'd think it would
jon vinyls thank you so much for the
super chat
hot take about orphan 55 the dregs are
genuinely creepy in concept i like that
the doctor leaves the resort to face the
consequences of
its actions um
i don't know how creepy i find the the
concept the design actually works when
they're in the tunnels
it looks like garbage
in the bright light of the day so i
don't know why they shot them in literal
daylight
but um
they looked good in heavy shadow
so i don't know why they made that just
why the director made that decision
uh if you could write your own original
doctor who villain what would you do i
mean the um
the the
concept i keep circling back on
is to really dig into
um the doctor encountering somebody
encountering somebody who hates them and
he doesn't know why now the show's kind
of done this like a little bit with
things like queen victoria in the
shakespeare code and stuff like that but
i would really want to dig into that as
a recurring thing and give it like truly
a sense of tragedy
where basically we're gonna do
sort of the villain version of river
song but the very first time the doctor
runs into this person
they
hate the doctor and the doctor has no
clue why
and then as
additional times encountering them
occur
just getting a fuller picture of what it
was that happened
and then eventually
having the doctor encounter them where
they're not mad at the doctor they don't
hate the doctor
and really bringing a sense of tragedy
to that that's my general concept i need
to map the hell out of it and i'm not
going to do that unless i've been paid
to
work on it
uh if we're talking badass female
characters may i throw barbara
uh in the 1990 night of the living dead
that's only because it's patricia
tallman though i mean whatever worked
for you have i seen peaky blinders i
have not captain omni thank you so much
for the super chat
joe quesada tried to get mafisto to be
used at the end of the clone saga even
back then he who was obsessed with
making mephisto a spider-man villain the
clone saga is just such a mess and there
were multiple points where if they just
stopped
it would have been good or at least not
a mess
anyone remember tank girl a comic or the
movie never read the comic i have seen
the movie
it's
not good but it is
fun have i seen the musical version of
christmas carol with albert finney no i
have not
speaking of forescape i'm worried that
from your pose it looks weird but is it
weird for the sake of it or is it like
doom patrol where there's a method to
the madness you know
it it is weird
all right
it's weird in the sense of it's
uh
the what is normal on farscape as a much
wider box than what most things would
consider normal so within the world of
farscape all of the weirdness makes
sense
and it all fits and it is and it
feels like the same
uh world in the same
universe that it's all happening in so
it's a very consistent weirdness in
terms of the overall vibe oh meg you
have to go okay hope everything's all
right please take care
see you later
uh
you've said uh you know how you would
play your own version of the doctor
do you know what you would do with the
show if you were given the job of
showrunner uh no i don't
because that's honestly a lot more
thinking time to devote to it whereas
you know thinking about how i play the
part doesn't require me to think about
how the part would be written so that's
easy for me to just idly uh think about
whereas think about what i do as a show
runner means like really plotting out
story concepts and
like i kind of said before i'm not gonna
do that
uh unless it's something that i can
actually make something out of what i'm
sinking my thinking time into or if i'm
being paid to do it
so
what kind of chocolate do i like uh dark
and white
if i could travel back in time where
would i go
uh
2004 get myself to buy some apple and
some disney stock
uh
not me that remembered if it was someone
else in the chat but have you seen the
catherine tate christmas carol with
david 10 as the ghost of christmas
present i have not
not seen that one
i like your top thank you
i love this top
uh i don't wear it very often because
um at this point in my life this is a
crop top
it was not supposed to be
it is now
i watch the season two episode off your
recommendation i'm confused and i want
more that is a good reaction to have to
farscape what is france
france is a state of mind
a way of being
not a place but a philosophy
a way of viewing the world
of consuming all the niceties
and the fineries that everything has to
offer
to think and take it in
as friends
something like that i don't know
have you seen marvel's version of
dracula because who boy world of
warcraft called they want their armor
back
um i'm assuming you mean comic versions
of dracula from tomb of dragon and
whatnot i know it exists
um
i haven't actually read any of those
so on who villains a version of aggro
jag from hitchhikers as the villain
basically yeah
uh that that would be the elevator pitch
new york state of mind oh you don't want
a new york state of mind
no no that's not good for you
uh
started playing d d with a group of
friends uh we're currently on a quest to
find the missing alcohol stolen from a
kingdom as they have no more left
oh don't you fail that quest
oh that is a dire state of affairs oh my
goodness
uh
yes good eye carolyn this is this is uh
an amy brown design on the uh on the top
uh the one scene from the indians
lantern that i wish wasn't a better
story
was start from the beginning
tell me everything you know
here's what i wish
i wish
that the wire the actors who plays are
in the general concept of the wire
didn't fall apart halfway through the
story and was in a much better
story because
early on
when she is
evoking
that
you know presenter that family tv
presenter
are you sitting comfortably then we'll
begin she's so good and she's so
freaking creepy
and then they just have her screaming
the same three lines over and over again
for the entire latter half of the thing
and then the other stuff that i hate
happens so
yeah
john finals thank you very much thoughts
on music by sia have not seen it won't
see it um
she did not handle um
the pushback from the uh autistic
community well and you kind of have to
if you're getting pushback from the
community you're attempting to depict
i understand that could be hard to hear
but
you better
not
make an ass of yourself
and she did
that's not even getting into the movie
which
i've heard enough about it don't want to
watch it
ah
do i like the song iris by the goo dolls
yes i like that song quite a bit
i don't want the world to see me
cause i don't think that they'd
understand
a bit of a heads up for your take two
reviews even being highly intoxicated
didn't make the witchfinders any better
well i'm not doing drunk reviews so that
wasn't going to help me anyway
any recommendations for getting into
comics
not at this point because i'm not
current in comics i like i grab
the occasional um
uh why can't i think of words graphic
novel um here and there but like
i don't know it depends on what you want
out of comics i suppose because
generally when people say how do i get
into comics they're talking about
superhero comics because that's where
that's a legitimate question because
like how do you pick what hero you want
to or you want to follow how far back do
you go do you just jump in on what's
current or whatever whereas anything
that isn't part of a greater
printed universe it just started the
beginning you know things like um you
know game and sandman just start at the
beginning um you know plenty of great
limited run
comics just start from the beginning and
read it um so
the question of how do i get into comics
as a medium pick something that looks
good and start reading it how do i get
into superhero comics specifically i
don't know and i suspect the answer for
marvel and dc is probably going to vary
anyways
that's a question better suited for i
don't know
nerdsync or comic drake or linkara maybe
the odd the autism council will see sia
now i'm autistic i can make these jokes
[Laughter]
do i free write no
not really
um
i really need to like have a plan i need
to have a purpose for me to get any
writing out of me um have you ever heard
of the anime berserk um
if it is the it is the inspiration
behind dark souls fair warning is
extremely dark but a great piece of dark
fantasy i've heard of it
like just so far as i know it's a thing
that exists
but i know nothing else about it uh yes
adrenaline jessie made a great video
about uh about that movie so
yeah and i'm not gonna say i'm not gonna
automatically default to and i agree
with everything she said because i
didn't see the movie but like
she made a really good analysis i'll say
that
have i watched much of the twilight zone
or the outer limits uh more of the
twilight zone than the outer limits
but i've seen a little bit of of each
from like from different eras too
original twilight zone still holds up
frighteningly well
it's one of those things that like for
how old it is you're watching now it's
like you have no business being that
good
what the hell
tea dragon one thank you so much for the
super chat love to your videos on the
good place wondering if you've seen
cloud atlas i
have
i like cloud atlas quite a bit it's one
of those movies that
i have a hard time
recommending because it
it's weird
and there are a million reasons to
dislike it and or be put off by it
but it landed right for me i liked that
movie quite a bit
i'm imagining that the people who did
videos ripping into the direct-to-video
films bruce willis has made in the last
few years are feeling really bad right
now they're probably not
you overestimate the ability of people
to feel shame
my favorite children's author um
if you'd asked me at the time i probably
would have said bruce coville
either that or bill waterson but like
that's kind of cheating because he was a
comic strip uh writer and artist
and to call that a children's author is
a little bit of a stretch
oh headed out logan well you have uh you
have a good time good rest of your
evening
uh have i ever read the brothers crim or
hans christian anderson books uh
directly
i think i've read
a couple of hans christian anderson
i've never read the like the root
stories for brothers grimm
cloud atlas has two of the curse of the
fatal death doctors that's true that
didn't occur to me you're right it does
uh what's my favorite tim curry moment
whoo
[Music]
um
there's just this one little moment in
rocky horror during the song sweet
transvestite and i don't know if it's
improvised or if it's in the uh or if
it's in the lyrics
or he's just like hit it bam and pops
his hip i'm like that's oh
you didn't have to do that but you did
and i love you for it
uh my favorite series from the twilight
zone era was tales from the dark side
never saw that one i haven't heard of it
though being british watching the good
place bloopers kind of put into
perspective how much uh we rely on
swearing
[Laughter]
the bloopers on that show are a lot of
fun
supreme omega have i been saying omega
supreme i feel like i've been reversing
your name
every other time i've said it supreme
omega
thank you for the super chat about the
90s death of superman event did it
really ruin the concept of death in
superhero comics because the writers
always planned to bring him back
yes it did
because regardless of whether or not the
writers plan to bring him back
they
marketed it like they weren't going to
bring him back
so
and when you say that
it ruined the concept of death in
superhero comics
you're talking about two different
things
one you're talking about the writing
because and it ruined it in both ways
because with the writing
it basically said undoing any death is
up for grabs now that's not to say that
deaths were never undone
um in superhero comics before but they
were pretty rare they were pretty rare
pretty
selective
when you build an entire event around
killing knowing you're going to bring
somebody back that kind of puts all
things on the table for the writers and
as far as the readers are concerned if
you're going to make this big massive
deal out of we are killing superman and
then you bring him back the readers
don't believe that anyone's dead and
stays dead
which
is to the detriment of the medium
true resurrections
generally uh in comics were reserved for
villains
they were reserved for bringing villains
back from situations where it looked
like they they would have died
and that was generally pretty accepted
but even there there were still some
permanent deaths of villains
for a while norman was born was dead for
decades
but
with heroes
generally if they died
they stayed dead at the point where
superman
um was killed you know
um dan garrett stayed dead while he's
still dead uh barry allen
stayed dead
through that um
bucky stayed dead jason todd stayed dead
but that really did kind of um
open the floodgates and
just everything's on the table now
death has far less meaning
these days uh in the comics and
i'm not gonna say that if they hadn't
done the death and return of superman
story that that never would have
happened it probably would eventually it
probably would have happened in some
form sooner or later because of just you
know
escalating event
you know just the nature of trying to do
bigger and bigger stories it was going
to happen sooner or later if it wasn't
superman it would have been somebody
else
but that is kind of the demarcation line
where
it starts becoming a thing
weird question what's the blue light
reflected on your glasses i have a ring
light right there to light up my face so
when i tip my head up it's reflecting
the ring light
um oh erica there was a super chat from
you
thank you very much um
finally able to catch a live stream wish
you a belated happy birthday oh thank
you
thank you erica i appreciate that
um
have you ever seen a movie that bored
you to sleep
no
because if i fall asleep during a movie
it's usually because i'm too tired and
too comfortable
not just flat out bored
actually that's not true
that's not true
uh it happened once that was the arthur
remake with
oh god what's his name
i can't think of his name now
i fell asleep in the theater
watching that which is the only time
that ever happened
best and worst tv show um
you've ever seen ever
best is hard
uh and worst is impossible
uh best is hard because like
there's just a lot of things that really
deeply mean a lot to me things like the
max which i mentioned already
uh the good place
um just a lot of
shows that
you know mean so much to me deeply and
like and stayed good
because there's other things that like
they were good
but that russell brand thank you folks i
know it started with an r um but
you know they were good but they didn't
hold it so but there's a few
worst i don't have an answer to because
if i don't like a show i don't keep
watching it
and i don't feel comfortable calling
something the worst of anything if i've
only seen like three episodes but i'm
also not gonna stick around and keep
watching it
so
you have to be a more dedicated tv
viewer than me
to power through things you hate i think
probably the thing that is the worst
that i forced myself to finish was
probably iron fist
and i got through that on sheer spite
i just i knew discord thank you carowind
i will get on that in just a minute um i
like i knew i was going to do a
review of that and i knew if i was going
to i was gonna have to finish it
but uh
[Music]
boy
i hated that so much
that was that that's probably the worst
i've actually finished
um
thought you almost fell asleep during oh
jon violence thought you almost fell
asleep during her on her majesty's
secret service i think again it was
because i was i was too tired when i
chose to watch it anyway i gotta pop
into the discord
be back in just a minute
all right
can't stay up tonight i think but
inspired by the upcoming special one of
the worst moments of classic who is in
worries of the deep when the female
scientist tries to kung fu kick the
murka
god yes that was one of the stupidest
and like the merka looks so bad
in that story and she tries to karate
kick it it's so dumb
anything to rival that combination of
terrible idea and execution
and a momentary scene of new era doctor
who in your opinion
oh not off the top my head
like that's just such a monumental fail
like both visual execution and just like
why why would you try and karate kick a
sea monster what
it's so dumb
it's so dumb i'm not sure modern who
has a proper equivalent to that
oh what else we got my favorite scene
from farscape is in wait for the wheel
where rigel the saltiest of salty crew
members uh breaks down and says what
will i do without you you big beautiful
blue [ __ ]
rigel's a piece of work
what will you do dominar is honor the
council i've given you by keeping it
yep
uh
zanzan was good stuff
um
you know virginia haye was was right to
leave the show given
uh that the makeup was literally killing
her um so
she was she was uh she was right to
leave but uh zan was good stuff
all right uh i am back now just say
shira for the best show you know the
truth it's up there it's in it's in the
conversation have i ever walked out of a
theater no i never did i did for roman
and juliet when they said draw thy sword
and the dude you were going with sword
written on it that's when i walked out
like honestly john i'm gonna say if that
made you walk out of the movie you did
not know what you were in going into
now if that made you go oh i didn't
realize what i was in for and i'm not
here for this fair but like
that that kind of was the vibe of the
thing
uh anime recommendations railgun index
and the ancient magnus bride
um
i think i've heard of the ancient magnus
bride i haven't heard of the other one
do i prefer bucky barnes or loki why are
we comparing those two there's no reason
to compare them
so i
uh
don't understand
why you would ask me that
i'm curious to know uh who you like to
see as the 14th doctor personally i've
done um
i did a video a year or so ago with uh
with my picks for who i think would be
really good uh more recently i would
like joe martin to be the 14th doctor
whatever
logistical technobabble gobbledygook
they need to say to make that viable
that's what i would like assuming she
wants to do it
i don't know if you like poorly animated
doctor who it's got jokes like the
doctor defeating the cybermen by showing
them the beauty that is love
and mons the beauty that is loving
monsters to get an emotional reaction
um i'd probably like a little bit of it
i probably wouldn't be able to stick
with it though
i'm just picky and grumpy
uh have you read the 1986 alan moore
superman strip whatever happened to the
man of tomorrow i have not i know what
happens in it
i'm familiar with it i have not read it
myself though
excuse me
it was just because i was very tired but
i fell asleep while watching knives out
in the cinema whilst i was on a date oh
ooh dang
[Music]
um
thoughts on our flag means death uh let
me get more than one episode into it my
general opinion right now is i hope i
like it better
if you enjoy steven universe you're
gonna love adventure time no i am not
no
no
no
no
i've heard so many people now say that
the
catradura ship shira is toxic scene
capture is a serial abuser any thoughts
anyone who's claiming that who has
gotten to the end of the show
missed the fact that the entire last
season is dedicated to hammering home
the idea that catra is working on
getting better is it a guarantee that
she will get better no but it is
important
that
she
work on it and she is she wants to
change we see her working to change it
acknowledges things like backsliding and
needing to avoid old habits and old
situations it acknowledges all these
things and pushes her through that is it
a abusive relationship prior to that yes
absolutely and anyone who wants to make
the argument that someone who has been
through what catcher put a door through
should never take them back in a real
life scenario i won't even disagree with
that but the way it is framed in the
show no i dispute that it is handled
very very carefully
to make sure that regardless of what you
think about real world ways to handle
this within the confines of the show
she is working
very hard and it is depicted in a way
that is believable and credible
to my view
do the youtube things
thumbs up subscribe hit the bell stay
hydrated yes all the things
good good recommendations emily
i'm gifting that no
have fun
go nuts have at it
is there a question you've secretly
always wanted someone to ask you if yes
what is it and how would you answer it
um
probably
but i can't think of what it would be
so i can't answer the last the second
half of that
here's what i'll say
i'd love to answer more questions about
like things i've written
uh like my book or my play
but i also know that's such a niche
conversation that like this probably
isn't the forum for it anyway because
most of the chat wouldn't have a clue
what the question would mean or what my
answer would mean
i have now completed season one of
gravity falls really excited to watch
through the rests now
gravity falls is good stuff
uh poorly animated doctor who also had
mickey smith be recast and when the
doctor calls attention to it he's pulled
away to the side and told what noel
clark did
okay that's kind of funny
uh my twitter becomes nothing more than
vera memes this is my life now i accept
it
embrace the madness
uh
gravity falls so good i should re-watch
it sometimes it's worth re-watching
and like
the show's good even at the beginning
but
second season's bonkers
just got my copy of dreams of fire today
oh great sailor twilight i hope you like
it i hope you enjoy it
later this week
i'm finally ordering the remaining
copies that need to go out to my
kickstarter backers so i can have those
out and be done because i wanted to have
this done last year but i screwed up so
i couldn't afford to
get it dealt with
but i hope you i hope you enjoy it
i also need to get back to editing the
audiobook
lord
jon vinyls ah thank you so much best
movie bob video i really love his one
division stuff i actually i don't watch
his stuff anymore
um
i liked
i mean like his his whole takedown on
batman v superman all three parts that
was very good
i think partially just because it's my
favorite movie i really really like
um
his first
episode of really that good which was on
ghostbusters
i like that one a lot
uh okay give us a bad movie description
of your book also i read skirting gender
and i loved it oh thank you renee a
bad movie description
uh
i'm not sure exactly what is meant by
excuse me bad movie description
so i'm not i'm not entirely sure how to
proceed sounds fun i'm not entirely sure
what the parameters of that request are
though
uh
let's see
want to review
more books on my channel first uh will
be i am legends second i'm hoping dreams
of fire oh
i am legends that that's a good book
oh hello leo richards shout out to my
friend annie gur
okay
shout out to your friend annie cheers
non-spoiler babylon five-pointed border
of warlords having counter suits not
exposure suits you'll thank me later
okay
my bad then
um
my thoughts on the iron giant giant best
movie brad bird ever made and probably
best movie he will ever make
so there's that
uh considering that he's been in family
guy in the cleveland show
i'm surprised i'm a little disappointed
that david lynch didn't agree to voice
bill cipher
i'd
who knows the mind of david lynch
i'm not sure david lynch knows the mind
of david lynch
reading i am legend after having covet
is interesting ooh
yeah
oh i can i can imagine it would be
however have i ever seen thunderbirds
the original series nope i know what it
is
i do know like who jerry anderson is and
what he did i never watched any of his
shows though erica
thank you so very much vera memes would
be a great band name oh what what would
the uh
what would the
music genre be for vera memes i'm
curious now
um
is there a film adaptation of a book
where you thought the book was better
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
always always and forever not a fan of
the incredibles the incredibles is fine
it's overrated
uh in my view
um incredibles 2 is not good
um
but
incredibles is
fine
i have philosophical issues with the
incredibles now that doesn't make it a
bad book
sorry bad book bad movie
but
what's my book called and where can i
and where can you buy it my book is
called dreams of fire the author is
listed as nathaniel wayne you can buy it
on amazon but because it can be acquired
through a company called ingram it can
also be acquired by any local bookstore
or your local library let them know it's
available through ingram they will know
how to get it
oh leo richards thank you very much
we're almost out of time so we're going
to wrap it up soon
uh who's your favorite doctor capaldi
capaldi all day long
do i like the thundercats franchise i
have nostalgia for the thundercats
franchise
um
that's about all i've got i
i don't have a ton of uh investment in
it but i have nostalgia for it i watched
it when i was a kid
bad movie description is like a meme
that went around social media somebody
described a movie really inaccurately
example twilight emo girl falls in love
with corpse okay so bad movie
description of my book
um
hot young man in the big city
would be the bad description of my book
[Music]
oh lord
i should not have found that as amusing
as i did
oh gail me thank you
very generous first timer to one of your
streams just wanted to say hi and thanks
for the content well thank you for
joining
um we are wrapping it up soon but i'm
glad you made it all the same and i
greatly appreciate that thank you
uh x-men but make it steampunk that
works too uh how much of the sarah jane
adventures have you seen i saw i think i
saw all of the first season in bits of
the second
it just it didn't grab me like it's
aimed at a younger demographic so like
it didn't really need to grab me but you
know
um
so all right that's it we are going to
wrap it up
oh i've got
stuff to do i need to get um
i need to get the saturday's video up
for early access for the patrons
um so we are going to
um
we're going to wrap it up there
so thank you all
for joining me oh supreme omega sneaking
in at the last minute oh
on gwen stacy's death
is it really an example of fridging
because it didn't just affect peter it
affected the rest of his supporting cast
so
here's what makes it not fridging
um
and it doesn't have to do with how many
people it impacts
what makes it not frigging
is that
there are more story at the point at
what gwen was at that point in the story
and like
where they were going and sort of the
options available
there were more stories that could be
told with her death that could not have
been told under other circumstances
then could have been told with her
continuing to live
that's one of the main reasons why
i don't consider it to be fridging some
people might still
but it it is a case of
the the impact of her death
expanded
way beyond this is another thing
expanded way beyond the immediate need
to
motivate peter to do like a thing if if
like the impact of gwen's death began
and ended
with driving the final fight between um
norman and peter then it would have been
fridging
but like her death has
haunted
peter
ever since
and the way in which they've done that
it's a way that could not be
accomplished even with uncle ben
it's a different kind of hurt it's a
different kind of burden that he carries
and that that i think is a big part of
the difference
uh twitch yes thank you carolyn tomorrow
twitch 10 30 a.m eastern daylight time
continuing on with undertale i'm loving
that game it is great uh one last super
chat got snuck in john vinyls uh wish
there were more stories showing the
development of societies and
civilizations across the centuries and
millennia after the apocalypse
um
i i i would say there's definitely room
for more stories like that i personally
don't love those kind of
wide stretch stories not uh not in
like written form at any rate i'd be
interested to see something done
long-form television
or maybe even like a more abstract film
maybe with minimal or almost no dialogue
i think that could be fascinating but
anyways we're going to wrap it up thank
you so much everybody you take well
you take well you take care
you be well
you'll be safe you be kind and remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i am just running
the meetings and until next time
this council
is adjourned
my cavity
[Music]